الحديث مع الموتى اصبح ممكنا هذه امنيه
اقرب الى المعجزه لكن الذكاء الاصطناعي قد
يحولها الى حقيقه ولو بشكل افتراضي
شخصيات رحلت عنا سنستطيع التواصل والتحدث
مع نسخ رقميه منها بفضل تقنيات الذكاء
الاصطناعي عام 2017 توفي رجل امريكي يدعى
جون جيمس اثر صراع طويل مع مرض السرطان
ابنه رفض الاستسلام لحزنه على والده فلجا
الى تطبيق ذكاء اصطناعي صممه بنفسه دمج به
عددا كبيرا من المعلومات والفيديوهات
لوالده التطبيق استطاع تكوين نسخه رقميه
للوالد الى ان تمكن الابن من التحدث كل
ليله مع النسخه الرقميه من ابيه
كنا نفتقد والدي ولا استطيع ايقاف هذا
الشعور لكنني وعائلتي اردنا فقط الحفاظ
عليه باي طريقه ممكنه وتسجيل قصه حياته
عبر تطبيق داد بوت وهو روبوت محادثه
تتفاعل معه على فيسبوك ماسنجر يسمح لي او
لاي شخص يستخدمه بارسال رسائل صغيره او
استعاده الرسائل لاجراء محادثه كما كانت
مع والدي وسؤاله عن اجزاء مختلفه من حياته
وجعله يروي قصصا عن ذلك
شركه في كوريا الجنوبيه تدعى
تمكنت من تطوير تلك التقنيه بشكل كبير
وصلت الى تقليد صوت المتوفى وتعابير وجهه
بشكل دقيق جدا واجراء محادثات معه ليبدو
وكانه لا يزال على قيد الحياه ولم يفارق
الدنيا قط
في كوريا الجنوبيه تمكنت شركه اي اي من
تطوير تقنيات اعتمدت على خلق نسخ افتراضيه
لشخص ما هذه التقنيات يمكنها تقليد صوته
وتعابير وجهه ومن خلالها يمكن للاخرين
انشاء محادثه فيديو افتراضيه مع هذا الشخص
بعد وفاته كل ذلك باستخدام الذكاء
الاصطناعي
تلك التقنيه الثوريه اثارت العديد من
التساؤلات حول اليه عملها
وامكانيه وجود اثار نفسيه لها على القائم
بالاتصال اعداد الشكل الدقيق للنسخه
الافتراضيه لشخص ما يتطلب جلوسه امام
الكاميرا لفتره لا تقل عن سبع ساعات حتى
يتمكن الذكاء الاصطناعي من التعرف على
صوته وتحركاته وتعابير وجهه كما سيتم
الاحتفاظ بكل ما يفعله هذا الشخص على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي من اجل رقمنته
وحفظه في سجل ارثه المعلوماتي وبالتالي
يتمكن اقاربه من التواصل معه افتراضيا بعد
وفاته
بواسطه تحميل البيانات الرقميه له عبر
تقنيات الحوسبه السحابيه سيعمل الذكاء
الاصطناعي على ابتكار شكل شخصيه مجسمه
تتحدث مثل الشخص المتوفى وسيتم ارسال رابط
دعوه للمستخدمين وعند فتح هذا الرابط
سيكون بمقدور المستخدم التواصل مع النسخه
الرقميه البديله للمتوفى
معاناه الفقد تجعل بعض الاشخاص يلجاون الى
فعل اي شيء للوصول الى حاله تشعرهم بوجود
من رحل عنهم وهو ما قد توفره لهم هذه
التقنيات الجديده من الذكاء الاصطناعي الا
ان الخطر هنا يتمثل فيما يحذر منه باحثون
في هذا الشان فمهما كانت الدقه تلك النسخه
الافتراضيه من الشخص المتوفى الا انه في
النهايه يبقى مجرد وهم ولا وجود حقيقيا او
حسيا له وبالتالي يمكن ان يكون لذلك مفعول
عكسي عليهم ويؤدي بهم الى مزيد من التعاسه
والاكتئاب
[موسيقى]